a qué distancia esto de correr un
triatlón cómo se puede decir de la
palabra el triatlón combina tres
disciplinas deportivas natación ciclismo
y pedestrismo o más conocido como
carrera a pie para saber a qué distancia
estoy es bueno saber dónde me encuentro
pensando en estas actividades
casi todos podemos decir que sabemos
correr corrimos o lo hacemos actualmente
quizás casi todos sabemos andar en
bicicleta o al menos lo hicimos en
nuestra infancia y un grupo un poco más
reducido sabemos nadar o al menos
tenemos una técnica particular de
desplazarnos en el agua pero por los
triatlón es más que nadar andar en bici
y correr esto juntos en un mismo evento
uniendo una y otra disciplina de la
mejor manera posible para explicarlo
mejor queremos compartir un breve vídeo
que ha facilitado la unión de tres la
trias gran del uruguay
[Música]
[Aplausos]
este vídeo corresponde a una fecha del
campeonato sudamericano de triatlón que
se realizó en la ciudad de montevideo en
el año 2019 podríamos empezar hablando
algunos detalles técnicos decía atrás de
triatlón tengo empezar a entrenar o qué
materiales demostrar pero en estos
tiempos el pensamiento social y cárcel
de casa pensamos que lo mejor sería
correr
nuestro primer triatlón si ya mismo con
algunos recuerdos que todos tenemos algo
de información e imaginación
imaginemos una mañana soleada de verano
temprano en la mañana nos encontramos a
orillas de un río si quieren podemos
buscar algún recuerdo o alguna situación
que nos resulte familiar puede ser una
ayuda a la playa e intentar recordar las
sensaciones los olores la brisa la
sensación de la arena en los pies y cómo
acercarnos a la orilla se vuelve más
fresca y firme ahí estamos junto a más
de un centenar de personas ya tuvimos
tiempo de dejar nuestra bicicleta demos
materiales en la zona de transición
repasamos mentalmente los detalles borra
bien colocada metes bien puestos para
que no entre nada de agua y la de esta
puesta en la primera boya que se de
pequeño al río deseamos buena suerte
buena carrera a todos los que nos rodean
y ansiosos esperamos la largada tras
unos segundos que se nos hacen eternos
suena la sirena y salimos corriendo
todos hacia el río rápido velozmente a
los saltos para adentrarnos todo lo que
podemos hasta que éste nos vence y nos
lanzamos a nada comenzamos a abrazar
alegres pero un poco nerviosos somos
muchos y es imposible lo tocaremos en
es decir alguna patada o algunos notas o
vamos a llegar pero es todo cuestión de
aguantar de ese momento y lograr nuestro
lugar el sol brilla y se refleja en el
agua por lo que a veces se nos dificulta
ubicar la boya pero sólo es cuestión de
cuidar el rumbo gracias con fuerza y
cada tanto mire hacia adelante llegamos
a ésta y nos encontramos con otro de los
puntos cautivos de esta etapa son muchos
y todos queremos hablar lo más cerca
posible aguantamos un poco este momento
de tensión y seguimos doblamos en una
segunda boya y toma una referencia en la
costa de hacia dónde nos dirigimos
cuando nos acercamos a la orilla ya
logramos tocar el fondo del río por las
manos es momento de incorporarlos por lo
que comenzamos nuestra corrida hacia la
zona de transición un poco torpe al
principio a la vez que nos quitamos la
gorra y lentes de natación temblando con
mucha dificultad tiramos la gorra de
lentes en el cajón colocamos en los
chamos cascos descolgado en la bici y
salimos corriendo hacia la línea de
monte donde un salto subiremos a ésta y
tras una estirada nos pondremos ahorros
de otros competidores con quienes aún
siendo rivales intentaremos luchar para
alcanzar un grupo que hemos delante
pasan unos metros y ya nos toca a
nosotros tirar de este grupo por lo que
nos ponemos al frente
damos cadencia a nuestras piernas y
aguantamos la velocidad el viento golpea
pero sabemos que es momentáneo hasta que
otro compañero pase al frente y nos
permita bajar al fondo a recuperar en
este momento es todo cuestión de
trabajar en equipo
cada tanto nos tomamos unos segundos
para observar el paisaje sentir abierto
en la cara y experimentar esa linda
sensación de libertad que nos da la
bicicleta transcurre una vuelta tras
otra y llega el momento de bajar de la
bicicleta nos aproximamos a la línea del
monte y justo antes de ésta de un salto
bajamos y corremos ese nuestro lugar con
un poco de dificultad colocamos la
bicicleta en el gancho dejamos nuestro
casco en el canasto y tratamos de
ponernos lo más rápido posible las
zapatillas la respiración es agitada y
hace temblar nuestras manos y piernas
pero finalmente lo logramos y salimos a
la corrida sabemos que esta es la etapa
más sufrida de la carrera dado que es en
la que estamos más fatigados luchamos y
luchamos sufrimos sudamos pero aunque
parezca raro disfrutamos decenas de la
sensación de sentirnos podemos seguir y
agradecemos cada minuto de entrenamiento
aprovechamos cada puesto de hidratación
bebemos nos mojamos pero nunca paramos
de correr las piernas responden por lo
que en los últimos metros podemos
apretar un poco el paso y definir casi
como si ganáramos pero sin saber
exactamente nuestra posición
pasamos el arco la línea de meta y llega
a la paz ese momento de felicidad y
luego de unos segundos de descanso esa
subida de energía salvamos a nuestros
compañeros de carrera amigos vemos
nuestra posición y nos dirigimos hacia
la zona de recuperación donde
disfrutaremos de esas medias naranjas
como si fuera la cosa más rica
comentarios charlas anécdotas de cómo
cada uno vio la carrera finalmente nos
vamos a nuestros hogares contentos
motivados pero sobre todo deseando estar
nuevamente en la línea de largada para
dar nuestras mejoras y experimentar las
mismas sensaciones o mejores ahora sólo
queda ponerlo como meter nuestras mentes
les podemos asegurar que no se
arrepentirán al practicar triatlón tanto
en los entrenamientos de cada una de sus
disciplinas como en las carreras
experimentamos sensaciones físicas y
mentales que nos brindan enseñanzas o
aprendizajes que podemos aplicar a otros
aspectos de nuestra vida para nosotros
el triatlón es un deporte para todas las
edades y para toda la vida
en el caso de que tengo memoria simple
si una persona enérgica recuerdo que el
niño corría arriba para abajo por todos
competía en carreras de vuelta a la
manzana que organizar el jardín y poco a
poco me fue formando como los 10 años
empecé a entrenar el tiempo en una
escuela lo había en el parque y al poco
tiempo corrió en filmar carrera
promocional la cual era en tres
kilómetros pasó el tiempo y siempre me
está que en mi categoría ya pongo en
esta escuela empecé a participar en
fecha del duatlón infantil y al poco
tiempo uno deporte del buen combinaba
tres disciplinas ahí conocí a mi gran
amor el triatlón este menacho porque era
un gran desafío igual disfrutado mucho
más entrenar a pesar de que los
entrenamientos serán más laborales
al principio competida de forma
preocupada pero actualmente soy feliz
entrenando a doble horario para ser
mejor en este deporte que me ha
permitido conocer a muchas personas y
lugares el el triatlón es un estilo de
vida saludable tanto física como mental
que todos podemos adoptar
el caso es bien diferente al de facundo
siempre estuve bastante alejado del
deporte y tenía una vida bastante
sedentaria hasta que por el año 2009
algunas causalidades de la vida me
llevaron a comprar una bicicleta de ruta
con la excusa de acompañar a mis suegros
que tenía ganas de salir a rodar
francamente fueron pocas las salidas que
compartimos pero en ese momento me
enamoré de la bicicleta ya usted
ciclismo como deporte a matar que no me
salía a practicar lo cual le ocasionó
grandes cambios en mi vida y en mi forma
de pensar también más adelante llegó al
running eso que no estaba nada correr
francamente nunca me habría planteado
correr por placer pero eso dio la
posibilidad a practicar algún patrón y
competir alguna carrera que se hacía en
la ciudad en ese tiempo he escuchado
hablar del triatlón algo desconocido
para mí y es por eso que teniendo ya
unos 36 años siendo bastante grandecito
decidí ir a una piscina para aprender a
nadar y algún día correr un triatlón
algo que logré años más tarde
y hoy forma parte de mi vida entonces a
qué estás esto de correr un triatlón la
distancia no importa todos podemos estar
encaminado corre luna los invitamos a
ponerse como objetivo sobre la actividad
deportiva sus vidas ya me tienes
importancia lo perfecto esperamos que
estas ideas esta historia que
compartimos historia territorio
compartimos y estas experiencias
extiendan una chispa en su interior que
en algún momento les lleve a recorrer
este camino para participar de un teatro
muchas gracias